alors Yanis il faut savoir un truc c'est
que toi tu as côtoyé les plus grandes
stars nous ici on côtoie beaucoup Daniel
Moreau
[Rires]
toi tu as même dansé dans un clip de
Céline Dion oui ah ouais tu étais dans
le costume de Deadpool de Deadpool
regardez ah ouais Céline Dion
après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute je suis resté avec elle de midi
jusqu'à 2h du matin donc ouais
un jour qui restera gravé à vie elle te
disait quoi genre déjà chanté la chanson
dans l'oreille toute la journée un jour
c'est vrai et ouais ma chante un petit
bout de pour que tu m'aimes encore
[Rires]
j'ai compris tous les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes restés en contact ou pas avec
Céline non mais bon elle est géniale
j'adore moi je suis fou de Céline Dion
alors on t'a vu aussi qui on a eu
t'étais ami avec Hélène Pompeo Meredith
Grey Grey's
en commun à New York après un cours
était également pote alors là avec qui
attends parce que je sais plus
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment ouais je suis fan depuis
toujours donc ça c'est un des jobs quand
on m'annonçait ça qu'elle était
intéressé pour que je la cote j'y
croyais pas du tout comment ça arrive là
on te dit Mariah Carey veut que tu la
côte c'était pas de la danse c'était
vraiment du coaching justement apprendre
à marcher à prendre la positionner en
talon elle va elle redémarrer une
tournée donc je l'ai un petit peu
coacher sur des positions de corps on
appelle ça movement coach vous pourriez
coacher Siri par exemple sur des
mouvements
[Musique]
quand tu l'as rencontres
c'est pas grave ça non bien sûr
elle était super elle est géniale et
voilà pour le coup on sait très bien
entendu et c'est vraiment pareil à notre
souv mais plus que je retiens encore
plus parce que je suis fan depuis petit
de Marianne donc pour moi c'était
vraiment sur réel d'être deux semaines
avec nous on a Maria tarif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
S
et tu es en contact avec elle ou pas
encore non plus avec Marianne non plus
non je sais qu'elle voit si on n'a
jamais dit arrivé d'envoyer deux trois
messages je sais qu'elle est libre elle
m'envoie deux trois messages je l'ai dit
non mais c'est vrai moi aussi elle
arrête pas de m'écrire Di Maria lève le
pied ma chérie incroyable